[Musique]
bienvenue à 24,60 hors série la jeune
prodige du tennis canadien bianca
andreescu enflamme les terrains partout
où elle passe en 2019
elle a été nommée révélation de l'année
et le 10 décembre
elle recevait le prix lui mais voici
sérieux a souligné jim crow
mais pour cette émission ce n'est pas
elle qui nous livre ses secrets mais
plutôt son entraîneur l'entraîneur de
l'année au canada
sylvain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sylvain bruneau bon soir même à 24 soit
simple je pense que vous revoyez cet
extrait pour une des premières fois que
vous entendez votre voix qui dit je
crois en toi je croyais je crois en toi
je crois en toi tu es à peine enterrée
par la voie du stade rennais ce moment
là ce qui signifiait pour vous un peu
beaucoup d'émotion l'extase l'extase de
la victoire l'extase devoir bien que
remporté les internationaux des
états-unis c'est un sentiment un énorme
sentiment de fierté un rêve réalisé mais
l'importance de là foi en quelques c'est
votre moteur quand vous dites c'est
spontané ça je crois en toi je crois en
toi te présentes pas ça ça ne se dément
jamais elle va cette fois sont elles
bien qu'elle avait besoin je pense de
quelqu un qui était pour l'aider à
découvrir ce dont ils étaient capables
et puis où effectivement j'ai très
confiance et je partageais mais cette
phrase je crois en toi c'est importante
ces mots là aussi pour elle à ce moment
là et pour vous aussi
c'est la confirmation vous avez raison
de croire en elle
exactement effet se déclinent comment la
foi en quelqu'un c'est celui comment ça
se ressent comme chez vous avec avec
bianca c'était la foi en ses qualités
ses qualités de joueuse de tennis c'est
qu'elle était aussi comme compétitrices
d'arriver un jour dans des grands grands
moments à s'exprimer à être elle-même
sur le terrain à se libérer et jouer le
tennis qu'elle était capable
est-ce que je crois que c'était pour y
arriver si tous doit l'admettre je
pensais pas être un peu plus tard c'est
allé très rapidement mais ça c'est avoir
la foi que ton est le plus elle a des
grands sommets ce moment là est le
moment le plus
évocateur plus important le plus
émouvant de l'année pour vous comme
entraîneur sûrement il ya eu d'autres
bons moments là la victoire à ton tour
la victoire à angie l'oise mais de
remporter un grand chelem comme c'est à
new york avec tous les embûches
elle a eu beaucoup de blessures avant un
tournoi de jouer serena williams avec
une fougue qui était complètement
conquise par son adversaire donc les
difficultés d'arriver à remporter si
c'était extraordinaire
mais ces moments là c'est quelques
secondes nous disent aussi que ça ne se
fait pas seul et ça ça vous vaut
aujourd'hui le titre d'entraîneur de
l'année
vous êtes l'homme de l'année au tennis
là parmi tous les entraîneurs de ce
circuit à travers le monde ça doit
représenter quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire pour vous bien sûr bien
sûr certains c'est une année sur le plan
professionnel incroyable
l'ascension bien commencé on était très
loin au classement et puis les résultats
qu'elle a obtenus étaient quoi 150 55 ou
quelque chose comme ça était sous le
radar à une méconnu complète sur le
circuit et était pas attendu sauf par
quelques uns dont moi il faut excès que
2009 était une bonne année mais comme je
c'est un lieu très rapidement elle a
complètement explosé les clôtures à la
télé très rapidement lorsque vous avez
géré une période d'arrêt la de blessure
donc à ce moment là j'imagine qu'il ya
des doutes doivent s'installer pour
apprendre puisque logiquement ne
serait-ce que puisque logiquement à
surmonter et d'août
c'est sur les blessures dans son cas les
multiples blessures que sélection
survenu c'était très difficile c'était
de grosses embûches c'était des moments
qui était très peiné pour elle donc des
cas d'arrivée à new york de jouer au
tennis que l'a fait et puis c'est
tellement sale un parcours fulgurant
mais vous aussi dans la vie un parcours
fort intéressant parce que 2009 c'est
l'année de l'accompagnement de cette
grande réalisation
vous avez une décision importante à
prendre à votre parcours professionnel
en 2018 laisser l'ensemble d'une équipe
pour vous dédié à une athlète qui
passait toujours sous le radar ça a
était quoi l'élément déclencheur ou les
avais dit à ce moment là aussi des à ce
moment-là avoir confiance en vous
d'abord parce que c'est important vous
plus pauvres vivent en échec et
confiance à l'athlète
ouais bien sûr bien sûr ils étaient en
roumanie on était en coupe fed est en
fait c'est mon patron louis borfiga qui
m'a approché que d'ici là je veux je
vais faire un changement on était en
plein cours tranquille j'aime encore
et une approche et je veux faire un
changement dans la coupe fed s'est fait
15 ans que je fais la coupe fed soit
comme entraîneur ou comme capitaine et
finalement il dit je préférerais que tu
te concentres sur bien qu'en dresse coup
c'est un projet important pour tennis
canada dont on croit qu'elle peut faire
de belles choses
et puis on aimerait vraiment que ça
devient une des missions principales il
faut comprendre que moi ça fait je suis
en charge du téléski mince affaire
multiples années je pense à une très
bonne relation avec le gym chars
françoise abanda rebecca marino tout en
fait toutes les joueuses canadiennes et
là je sais que ça va vraiment brouiller
les cartes si je me concentre sur une
chose donc je suis très réticent au
départ de multiples conversations et
finalement c'est lui que le dernier mot
heureusement oui heureusement
et puis on connaît la suite et pourquoi
vous pourquoi ce monsieur a vu en vous
l'homme qu'il fallait pour l'accompagner
vers grands exploits qu'est ce qui fait
que vous êtes devenu parce que le tennis
vous avez connu se voir je peux pas
torse 15 ans vous avez étudiants en
éducation physique et puis vous êtes l
arpentinier instinct terre fertile pour
le tenir oui c'est votre patelin en plus
tous deux fils je suis de repenser je
suis à morialmé très très gênant on a
bougé se repenser donc sa vie après à
jouer au tennis c'est là que j'ai fait
mes classes comme instructeur comme
entraîneur pendant plusieurs années donc
le programme haarp ratier ça représente
beaucoup pour moi
mais pourquoi pourquoi moi le nom patron
ben je pense qu'il y avait confiance en
moi ça va soit dans mes qualités pour
recadrer justement face qu'il faut pour
permettre à bien co2 démontré son
potentiel
un nouveau collègue jean lapierre le
même ancien joueur de tennis je le cite
il dit de vous que vous êtes un génie du
coach et puis vous dire que jamais
qu'est ce que c'est pourtant là david
coach expo sur balles à ces jeunes la
pierre
est ce que cette vos patrons lui s'est
produit sans mes collègues et puis est
ce concept du tout renoncé à la coupe
rogers donc de très beaux mots
le coaching c'est un art je pense que
j'avais c'est un bon match ou bien quand
même moi c'est ça de la chimie était
impeccable donc de dépasser leur
facilité à la facilité le truc se fâche
j'avais oui c'est très rare que j'étais
assez calme et savoir faire et dire lire
le corps la psychologie d'un athlète
pour changer les choses
la faire progresser puisse une
progression absolument fulgurante une
ascension fulgurante
ça ça vous l'avez actrice vous si
l'expérience des années l'apparition
l'intuition
l'expérience des aînés d'avoir cette
vision là de voir une joueuse combien
quand une est le désert ok voici le
produit maintenant qu'est-ce que
j'aimerais qu'on produit final qu'est ce
qu'on doit développer dans son jeu parce
qu'on s'entend pour un athlète anthony
si aucun composant que l'aspect tennis
mais les stratégies mentales qui est
énorme l'aspect physique donc des câbles
de tous placés les quatre pouces et sur
des oeufs
et voilà où je veux en arriver à près de
faire le travail
j'ai compté dix pages parce qu'on a on
peut avoir la légende l'idée est une
légende urbaine de pirlo peut-être plus
sentie sowe ou dans d'autres sports
malheureusement au ski certains échos
qu'on a eu sa voix qu'on fouette les
athlètes ont vu les yeux en france se
voit par l'humiliation c'est du passé
ces choses là il faut il faut soutenir
je pense que wayne je pense à ça en moi
du moins de vieilles méthodes
qui ont peut-être fonctionner je sais
pas à l'époque mais on est on est
ailleurs maintenant et puis je pense
avec bien encore du mois mon approche
est tout autre c'est beaucoup un
approche axée sur wii être réaliste les
critiques mais beaucoup et très positif
les levés et c'est comme ça que je pense
que je retire le meilleur des mondes on
va l'écouter parlant de vous donc une
jeune femme reconnaissant une relation
aussi bonnes sur le corps j'ai lu que
vous alliez même mangé des cinémas il ya
une vie en dehors du tennis ou important
c'est très important parce que la vie
d'athlète c'est très exigeant les
demandes pour arriver au sommet comme le
disent faire c'est beaucoup donc faut
trouver le moyen de rendre ça
intéressant à l'extérieur du terrain
donc oui on le site jaurès et très
avantages qu'on s'entend très bien
l'extérieur serions-nous malgré notre
différence d'âge des deschamps comme un
intérêt donc on a de bonnes discussions
on rit beaucoup on mange des hamburgers
sert à faire une fois et c'est important
mais je pensais cimentation oui oui
effectivement mais ça c'était c'était
c'est à indian wells
on se souvient en mars dernier avait
remporté le tournoi et puis dans un
entraînement parler d'une chaîne
d'alimentation hamburger puis je
connaissais pas puis à midi on va y
aller
si je gagne le tournoi et puis c'est un
fait cocasse lorsque il ya une petite
fête pour elle après d'ailleurs on en
change le champagne parce que le pôle
âge pour de boire aux états unis et on
lui donne une carte cadeau de cette
chaîne
c'est ainsi il faut absolument qu'on
s'est rendu et là les gens
elle est devenue même en début d'année
en cours d'année oui son statut et là je
pense que c'était le premier single est
dans ce petit événement parce que je
suis présent l'auto je vais chercher
burger puis on a joué avec toi puis le
lait est venu avec moi et là c'était la
commotion tous les gens voulaient une
photo ou un autographe donc si on résume
un peu les choses ont peut-être changer
est évidemment oui son statut a beaucoup
changé sur plein plan sur le circuit les
fans
évidemment qu'ils sont vraiment ont
doublés triplés d'intérêt à venir voir
ses entraînements c'était assez marche
de voir une partie des aides pour donc
c'est ça le circuit parce que maintenant
elle est perçue comme une des stars
montantes celles qui peuvent promouvoir
vendre le tennis est passé par par les
autres joueuses aussi la perception est
tout autre
a single man a dit m donc ça demande de
votre part vous une approche aussi
protectrice peut-être ça donne il faut
la protéger les médias tf1 d'une
certaine façon oui désolé
on a vu beaucoup de joueuses qui ont qui
sont arrivés à voir très bon résultat et
puis après c'est difficile parce que
tout la pression comme je mentionnais
plus un peu plus tôt dans notre
entretien qui est finalement ce
manifeste donc il faut il faut être très
prudent il ya quand même des défis on va
avoir des petits pièges donc il faut
faut être très sage prendre les bonnes
décisions il faut pas s'éloigner de ce
qu'a très bien fonctionné jusqu'à
maintenant parce que maintenant il ya
plein de demandes
il ya plein de trucs très intéressant
qui lui sont offertes et donc il faut
savoir choisir et est resté dans sur son
chemin qui va changer votre vie et vous
aussi notamment comme un peu
l'impression que bien comme est le même
oui j'ai un niveau moindre mais c'est
certain que par le passé j'étais très
motivé parce que je faisais le tennis
canadien s'était c'est tout pour moi le
téléfilm canada est maintenant c'est sûr
que lorsqu'on se présente dans des
compétitions sur le circuit
international
il ya des attentes on est aussi un peu
plus épié donc c'est ference et je sais
la compétition peut aussi la pression de
renouveler cet exploit ou pour vous
enchaînez faire qu'il dure au fil des
années on va s'arrêter quelques minutes
sylvain bruneau on va poursuivre cette
conversation passionnante
madame messieurs restent habite nom
revient avec sylvain bruneau
l'entraîneur de l'année c'est l'homme de
l'année aux sports a tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un grand moment où elle savoure sa
victoire de vue des trois grands moments
de l'année
on a vu ses parents on a vu donc une
bien que se lancent au sol puis qui
savoure ce moment là c'est une femme
très très émotif c'est tout le portrait
très émotive spontanée ambitieuse et
audacieuse très très et alain côté très
sage aussi pour une fille de 19 ans pour
de 19 ans par sa demande énormément de
maturité parce qu'on l'a vue elle a
enlacé rénové donc je pense que ce
qu'après la coupe rogers qu'elle a elle
l'a rendu hommage à serena williams vous
avez parlé de compétition tout à l'heure
donc ça se vit comme un cette
compétition là parce que ça devait être
une icône pour elle fait oublier toutes
vues et leur même pour vous comme
entraîneur cédé 6 et des modèles a
atteint absolument absolument donc bien
colloque grandis tu ne m'a regardé jouer
sur une obédience remporté à peu près
chaque e silva chacun s'il tournoi et
puis vouloir un jour peut-être sur le
même terrain qu'elle et puis là se
retrouvent pour commencer c'était à la
finale à toronto aurait ensuite à la
finale avec son idole de jeunesse devant
elle et moi mon rôle d'entraîneur mais
c'est de l'aider à croire que non
seulement les ménages sur le même
terrain questionne voyance mais qu'elle
doit aller sur le terrain et puis
remporter ce match donc pas se laisser
intimider par ce que j'ai j'ai crû
comprendre qu un moment donné il y avait
de l'entraînement à proximité quelques
voulait l'éloigner de serena williams je
vous avais dit non non non c'est bon
c'est vrai c'est tout ça on s'est
préparé tout tournant du parc sur un
petit espace où elle faisait sa
préparation avant le match 15 20 minutes
après quoi ces ballons
quand la lancer toujours de jeu de
jambes pour se préparer arrivés sur le
tanit bief bien prête pour l'action et
donc on fait la même routine pendant
tout le tournoi et la rive la finale et
on s'entend tu peux partager cet endroit
là avec d'autres joueurs d'autres
joueurs s'est pas restreint du sud 1-2
ce josé les tribunaux et à vue avant
nous elle aussi pour les mêmes endroits
le quelqu'un dans l'équipe que ça serait
important que bien que je n'ai
absolument pas parce qu'on ait fait tout
discours elle va aller à se préparer à
côté des swing à et puis on fera pas
faux bond puis on démontre pas un
respect ou une crainte avant le match il
faut surtout c'est important que ce soit
entre entraîneurs ou entre athlètes de
bénéficier du respect alors vers les
autres qui est pas de coups bas ou de
tout à fait je crois au respect
énormément et bien que respecte
énormément
si on envoyait faisait les autres
joueurs du top-ten qu'elle a joué durant
l'année à l'interet bond aussi à peu
près sur tout le monde mais je pense que
c'est important tu peux pas vous
respectez la légende dessus serena a
quel âge 38 je crois c'est le double de
l'âge pour être la mère de bianca salle
avait eu jeu est-ce qu'on réfléchisse à
ce que cet exploit soit le plus dur dans
le cadre se prolonge parce qu'à 19 ans
elle doit regarder c'est un an dire dans
19 ans je veux être là et vous est ce
que vous vous projeter dans l'avenir
pour bien cas où pour vous même comme
entraîneur oui déjà rapidement
honnêtement c'est on a discuté bien que
moi et rapidement malgré l'année
incroyable 2019
on a tourné la page pour se concentrer
sur 2020 selon vous l'avenir
oui parce que c'était c'était des
moments là dit extraordinaire mais il
faut pas rester trop accroché au passé
on veut concentrer à faire en sorte qu'
on peut se reproduire
d'autres victoires comme celle là ce
sera pas facile est ce qu'il ya un
entraînement spécial pour se préparer
face à de tels athlètes de l'athlète
quarts de finale bis tient de finale
finale
il faut c'est comme un jeu d'échecs à
chaque fois c'est un
mario a offert à chaque fois pour vous
oui parce que bien qu'elle a les
qualités des caps d'adapter son jeu
selon chacune de ses adversaires donc
alain je traite pas du var les pins à la
pointe est née stéréotypes et de
s'adapter selon l'adversaire donc si on
joue c'est une âme au diable ou un
adversaire qui était tout autant
d'original
benchikha new york donc le plan de match
va différer la stratégie est différente
mois comme entraîneur je vais visionner
les matchs du week-end que avec elles ou
s'en est réunion je faisais sans elle
j'avais pris l'habitude au premier tour
comme ça c'est arrivé comme ça dans
l'eau traitée devant saint charles par
donc tard dans la soirée
j'allais visionner le match de premier
tour son adversaire et geminus est cette
routine parce que parfois les entraînant
tout comme les athlètes ont des routines
des rituels donc j'ai fait ça pendant la
quinzaine à new york donc parce que
l'athlète attend de vous des comptes
toujours être guidée vous est ce que
c'est votre patron ben je dirais pas que
c'est moi le patron mais c'est sûr que
c'est un mois que je lui arrive avec les
bonnes stratégies comme un jouet
continue une voyante qu'est-ce qui va
fonctionner qu est-ce qui va pas
fonctionner moi faire quoi ne pas faire
ou par exemple dans ce match au final de
bien commencer c'est essentiel
il fallait dès le départ avant la
première balle démontre à son adversaire
qu'il était là pour l'emporter qu'elle
n'avait pas parlé c'était très important
de faire du tennis de rattrapage arrêté
conflit
c'est un travail l'équipe les choses ont
bien commencé ont bien évolué parce que
quand on a commencé n'y avait pas
d'équipé c'est elle et moi maintenant on
a commencé tout seul au japon de mes
yeux c'était elle et moi tout seul il
est deux potes préparateur physique par
personne donc bien les choses avec sa
progression les choses mais l'équipe est
fantastique autour d'elle les
préparateurs physiques ayant le 2
clément gaulier virginie tremblay on
amène un préparateur aussi sur le plan
problème physio des puis quelqu'un pour
taper des balles avec le nom qu'on a une
équipe complète et puis c'est 31,6 nous
remercier très gentille et bien qu'en
être fait parce que il faut dire pour
devenir un joueur de cette trempe fois
durant faut être très compétitive il
faut avoir ce côté là très très doux ça
revient du kid de ses parents sûrement
et puis y égaler
mais elle a géré un super bel équilibre
en tête très dur sur un terrain très
coriace mais cadette
c'est à l'âge de 10 ans que tennis
canada l'a opéré qu'est-ce qui a
présenté à l'âge de 10 ans la belle
qualité déjà c'est pas moi qui le
financier mais les entraîneurs qui est
en place ont tout de suite vu qu'elle a
une aisance avec la balle avec les
raquettes une belle vision du jeu
déjà dix ans donc plusieurs joueurs qui
ont une âme est une pyramide de
plusieurs qui sont et qui sont
identifiés puis elle a très bien fait
les choses pour ses romans ou des
pyramides son rapport avec vous comme
mon francophones comme québécois
citoyens de repentigny sans doute un
citoyen aurait peut-être un jour et le
fait qu'elles doivent venir au québec
est-ce que vous pouvez nous est ce que
ça représente le québec montréal pour
elle et un excellent alors oui elle
alors que de bons souvenirs à le passer
du temps ici dans les familles à
montréal alors qu'il était plus jeune ça
fait plusieurs années qu'ils passent
beaucoup de temps pour s'entraîner ici
parfaire son tennis et puis elle adore
la ville pour la villa me le mentionner
souvent elle veut elle parle français
je crois plutôt bien mais elle veut
vraiment améliorer
d'ailleurs ce sont ses objectifs à la
coupe rogers à montréal on sait un mois
d'août d'être parfaite en france est de
faire plein d'entregent france oui pas
les tenues à porte une robe marie saint
pierre eglise un but évident mais quoi
c'est un coup de casque est aux
québécois et aux québécoises d'une
certaine manière est très fier très fier
de cet aspect là ici du temps qu'elle a
passé à montréal et que ça va continuer
avez vous l'impression qu'elle l'ait
déjà et qui a peut être un modèle pour
les jeunes pour la jeunesse oui pour la
quête d'excellence
est-ce qu'elle transmet comme valeur
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez vous que
qu'elles transmettent comme valeur la
résilience
je pense que c'est une qualité
incroyable belles qualités je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'elle va bien
véhiculer et puis
m compétitive sur le terrain d'être
audacieuse d'être déterminé je pense que
ce sont des qualités qui sont importants
dans le sport mais aussi dans la vie
donc et puis je pense qu'elle va être un
modèle incroyable pour les jeux le fuit
et les garçons parce que à l'extérieur
du terrain je le trouve très sympathique
très ouverte et scène ficelles
absolument c'est beau mais vous allez
deux filles
sans rentrer trop dans votre vie privée
14 ans dix ans elle joue au tennis mais
bon pas de elle rêve pas de devenir
comme bianca non non mais je joue au
tennis mais on fait plein sport c'est le
tennis parmi tant d'autres mais c'est
bien vous êtes bien placé pour savoir
comment le fait d'être père de deux
jeunes filles a pu vous aider à bord d
une jeune fille de 19 ans absolument
c'est est-ce que vous ont apporté des
mois et des mois
ouais comme entraîneur lorsque des
choses qui changent lorsqu'on devient
pas et avec des feuilles aussi parce que
je pense du moins l'approché différente
lorsqu'on s'adresse à un jeune fille ou
un garçon j'ai déjà trouvé des dégâts
les garçons les autres noms des athlètes
masculins puis je suis différent la
façon que je peux dire que vos défis un
rôle à jouer dans ce que vous êtes de
ceux qu'on connaît sûrement modifier la
quantité fait oui parce qu'elles sont
venues sur plusieurs compétitions bien
que très gentil avec un très bon rapport
de quoi rêvez-vous pour pour vous fait
d'abord pour mes filles d'être heureuse
enfin c'est surtout c'est d'avoir une
vie pleine d'aventurés mais surtout
d'être bien d'être bien et puis
le tennis va faire partie de leur vie
mais ce sera pas mal du tout la même
chose qu'avec bien qu'à mais je suis
passé en fait je veux qu'elle trouve le
rêve et l
et puis qu'elle fasse qu'un peu comme
moi puisqu'elle fonce vers la caisse que
vous souhaiter pour bien que je connais
pas la réponse que ce ce que 2019 ses
grands coups d'éclat où elle ou la
planète l'a découvert sur le plan tennis
ne soit que le début soit le tremplin
pour plein d'autres belles années parce
que je sais que c'est ce qu'elle
chérissait ce qu'elle soit un peu ce
qu'elle disait aussi en recevant son
trophée fournée de beginning c'est
seulement le début alors on a parlé de
serena tout à l'heure à la 2 fois
sondages donc est ce que vous pouvez
vous projeter aussi loin pour bien qu'à
avoir une longue carrière certains
dirigent vers les jauges de plus en plus
longtemps s'il en est un exemple sa
soeur venus morgan nadal federer donc
mai
non se projette pas sur moi en cause la
colonne est à la fois ci le même nous
est un plaisir de félicitations merci
une citation à vous pour votre honneur
merci entraîneur de l'année c'est par
des instincts bella bel exploit à
beaucoup de raquette
merci mesdames messieurs merci de nous
avoir suivis à fabien
[Musique]